hey guys it's dense defender take care
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic looking video game guru and its
back Game of Thrones oh yeah seize it
before been waiting for a whole year the
ratings came in its 6.6 million viewers
it's not even included in all the HBO
but not including the repeats or they
should be ago they said it's the the
most-watched HBO show since The Sopranos
finale and it broke HBO GO tonight some
friends less I turn to watch on HBO go
and it broke down HBO released some
snarky comments last I leave on Twitter
some other devices like they know that
people that are watched HP will go
during that time are probably borrowing
it from their friends literally some
comments like oh we're sorry like send a
raven you know if you have you know just
kind of being funny but I pay for my HB
meeting I got my rights Ryoga but
anyways season for producers yeah let's
get right into it King's Landing King's
Landing so before going into it I want
to say that i love the premier's that
game of thrones us especially since
season one it's almost like getting
reacquainted with old friends it's like
here's this person hears that person
hears this person so let's start at
King's Landing with Tywin Lannister
basically breaking down and please
correct me again people going to the
element criticize never read the books
in a while but i believe the sword is
called ice I believe please correct me
I'm finally being corrected let me know
if that's not a crime Ned Stark's old
sword broke it down into two different
swords 12 Jamie and we're assuming the
other one's going to Joffrey I don't
think we saw that and see that half but
I'm assuming unless he's gonna keep it
for himself but it was smaller some
guess he's probably gonna dry what a
waste to get I know right who job he
doesn't need anything but it's made of
Valyrian Olivia's which you can't get
air we actually brought a guy from
Valyria over to specially make that for
him so that was significant was great it
was the first conversation since you
know a few seasons back boys have to see
Tywin and Jamie shear have a
conversation together you can see the
pride in his father's voice before it
get turns bad much more than was talking
to Tyrion or even Cersei like he loves
his supposed to be his heir yeah his son
yeah even without you know even with one
hand gun well that's the thing is with
one hand he wants to stay in the
Kingsguard we think that's why thailand
gets pissed at him in it yeah you know
and then he also he's just having lots
of problems coming back to kingsland
he's fighting with Sir say
it's mad at him for like corn coo
leaving which I don't know that's really
old and her perspective you took too
long you took too long it's like you
went to go to war to help fight the war
that her son basically started right and
he got captured right so what is he
supposed to do yeah I mean everybody's
giving him crap I mean except for uh you
know um Brienne of Tarth season I wasn't
she's giving him crap but she was gonna
look up to for not for not looking out
for Sansa yeah not watching over the
deal was to send her like the deal was
he comes back he sends Sansa and Arya
back they didn't know at the time that
they have re Erin the but now that
sounds as married to Tyrion that's not
an easy thing to do right so I mean he
just he can't catch a break he's just
getting attacked from all sides he just
can't win but it was great I mean seeing
him back and it just being back in
King's Landing and actually talking to
all of his family I don't believe we
didn't get a conversation between him
and Tyrion yet no this episode so
hopefully well I'm sure we'll see that
we just haven't seen a competition
between them and then moving on then as
the episode progresses we get to see
Tyrion waiting outside of the right
outside the city gates waiting for this
princess Dornish Prince Oberyn man tell
who's the second son I'm kind of like
you know cheering is to Jamie from this
kingdom to the south and he is that's
probably one of the better character
entrances that I've seen his entrance
was great and the brothel I thought he
was just he's a cool character I mean
he's sex he goes both ways it seems like
he's violent he's like Jamie maybe even
more aggressive though but probably just
a skilled in terms of swordplay and
everything so I mean he's a really good
good what do you think of his character
not knowing him not meeting yeah and he
go what do you think you know seeing the
trailers in the previews and stuff I
knew that this character is coming and
you know they they say his nicknames a
red vibe right vibe for you so I kind of
knew this characters come I liked him
cuz he's very confident he is lagger
he's got you know he's got pretty much
the best ever we haven't seen a weakness
in him yeah yeah no we haven't he seems
to have it all they have they have
something against the Lannisters ya know
Tyrion finds out about why why he's
there right you know he tells that story
of his sister
and this was going to ask you I think I
was gonna see what you thought I love
Game of Thrones and that's one of those
shows that doesn't need to have an
action sequence or a sword fight I think
that one of the best parts of that hole
opening sequence with Oberyn Martell
coming is I love when he was talking to
tiering outside telling the story
cheering kind of looks down he lifts his
head up and Syrians know it's tough to
he kind of moves his hand out of the way
you know I mean that was a great matchup
from second son's who both feel like
they're not as good as their older
brothers and have something to prove and
I thought I mean it just they do so much
with so little on the show I think a lot
of the times yeah and also her companion
a Leary is it illyrius sand yeah i'm
gonna bid your name cuz so we know that
bastard's in the north their last name
they called snow jon snow in the south
yeah i believe it's here Sam yeah Sam
yeah they're all wherever you're
wherever you were born yeah right you
get certain last name yeah I remember I
think there was like george RR martin
did a little video on HBO and like they
explain it it's like seven or eight
different tangents right river right all
this other stuff and for those of you
that are familiar with HBO or Luther for
that matter she was a oba oba in Rome
Rome and she's a digicel Bhas wife and
Luther beautiful woman like half Indian
half swish gorgeous so I mean it's nice
to see her back I would see her in a
while so it's cuz here yeah and then
it's being a more King's Landing Jeff
Tyrion man they gotta get rid of shay
I've been completed on her like for many
many seasons I just don't like her
character I just here they are all this
stuff is happening Tyrion has so much on
his mind he's like worried about getting
killed worried about her getting killed
right or found out worried about all
these people Sansa his new wife he wants
to still protect even though he's not
sleeping with her yeah like all this
stuff in all she cares and I was like oh
you know hang out with me anymore yeah a
little whining Tyler whining like really
yeah so like yeah bye bye go away go
away go away she's a little whiny I
don't mind the I mean II of the
actresses in height she's not going I
don't like that actress but what I do i
do like they gave her a character more
depth in the book she's there but of
course you know the book is based off
chapters from using that looks like from
people's point you from bran from aria
from Cersei you get points of view but
you never get her point
necessarily so I like that she's fleshed
out a little more in the series but
could be I everyone out yeah she I mean
when she's in the scene with Tyrion you
know she doesn't really stand up on his
he's he's such a good actor he so yeah
so good and then with Sansa like she's
right obviously distraught and pissed
off because now her now not only is her
father dead now her her brother and
mother yeah it's it's like her and
re-adjust have had the worst awful worst
childhood I mean with with I know bran
and Rickon and Jon Snow they still there
still alive but they haven't been they
heard of all these things but they've
been kind of a way with Aria in Santa
they're there in the thick of it a
little gifts on sat crap well people
like even last night we had a party in
jail or say oh there's Santa she's so
boring I was like it'll give her some
credit I think she's strong i don't know
she's not out in the wilderness now
killing mofos and living with the hound
but she has her own strength it's
different but I think he's a stronger
and thank you that too just let's just
give give her a little time and then get
a give her time so keeping in King's
Landing we also get to see Marjorie yeah
Margaery Tyrell is better preparing for
this big wedding we got always call her
you know grant she's like the equivalent
of like a doubt now do you know
character the lady of the Dowager
Countess and you know putting for the
wedding and you'd see that she's I mean
shared he know what kind of guy Joffrey
is but you know she's see made some
comment about you know he would have me
where some you know neck with skulls or
something that's something I mean she
knows that she's marrying a monster I
don't think she's too happy about it but
you know she's this is what she has to
do well what was most interesting about
her scenes was that when Brienne came i
love that tell her the truth about how
Renly died Margaery doesn't really care
no she doesn't care like she wants to
appear that she didn't love him yeah no
she never loved him she just wanted to
be the queen right now and she at that
time she thought Renly was the best the
person at that time he actually was the
most suited also in the best position in
the biggest army met people that loved
him like he was most suited he probably
would have taken out Stannis's army and
then me and he was gonna join forces
with Robb yes they were they you know
Renly was very compromising unlike
Stannis's character who's very stubborn
he was willing to give up the north
for Rob and so those two together would
have taken at the Lannisters plus they
had the Tyrells it would have been you
know they would have won in sewed at
that time she's like okay that's that's
the horse that's gonna win that that
right she picked that horse yeah and now
she's all about the game yeah it's over
the game I'm Washington doing a rewatch
of the wire she's all about the game how
about moving up the ladder the political
ladder in this way um and so her
reaction to to Brianne was kind of like
oh yeah yeah I'm glad you brought this
two minute she doesn't care no she's a
cure but I do like her and your
grandma's I loved how when Brianne came
when I was like oh am I good like but
she was being nice she's like you're
just marvelous like she was just being
kind of nice and i like that you know
they weren't turned off by everybody's
been so mean don't even Jamie it says
well you know you know you could be a
Lannister but something you don't that
looks for even he kind of made fun of
her but you know they were really nice
to her like that they were nicer Brianne
cuz Branson cool character so it's nice
to her I think they're all so fascinated
by her because she's something different
I mean especially with with the Olenna
Tyrell she's she's old she's seen it all
yeah right stina know she wants to see
something new that impressed if she
wasn't meet people who go beyond her
expectations so there's someone that
she's narrating before her last season
they had all those scenes when I'm you
know everybody you know old people come
over to her and talk to various Kazarian
the only person she was impressed with
it was Todd time I went and now is it
was like I don't know a little too
you're up you taste like this is all you
got for me like even varies like ran off
its like I'll come back come on I want
to talk to you she's a great character
um before we get off of King's Landing I
do have to mention with the Jaime
Lannister scene with with Joffrey I mean
dropping before that they have Joffrey's
statue oh my god well that's a great cut
I loved how it had the statue of him
with the the direwolf underneath him
with the clips but to him like he was
posing in his role like / yeah i mean
because we love to hate him yes but he's
such a good a place that role so well
he's doing such a good job we just we
love to hate him he's a great character
name yeah and he was you know talking
down to his father who he thinks is his
uncle and like me Jamie could kill you
right now man I know if you only knew
but yeah it's a Jesus had some good
scenes also talk a little before leave
about Sarah see who's drinking more was
she drinking more last season to his
nothing new she drink all that Arians
footstep ontarians was it he's kind of
going in a dark she like has no
focus like she's getting dark I mean I'm
kind of glad even though incest decided
this is not good um I'm glad that she's
pushing Jamie way like you want to be
with her that girl's crazy okay she's
got some issues I'd rather liked him he
be with a Rehan or something well I mean
she's lost control of her suffering yeah
you know and with the Tyrells movie name
she's just losing more more power dad
called around yeah right time wins bag
so it really has lost a lot of her power
right all right all right so moving
towards uh what wills call this we're
gonna kind of go on by region here so
let's go to the wall area the North use
and Jon Snow and Ygritte separate
separate read the similar storyline so
well start with John he's back you know
back at dad no he's back inside dead
he's back at Castle black got three
arrows in him but of course is well
we'll go back to that and somebody
called figure it out for me look he's
like I've seen you shoot a pigeon
something at 200 yards like if you want
to kill him he should have been dead so
maybe her inner self was telling her not
to kill him but he's done a little bit
of fire right now he has all the men all
the heads of the at the the black castle
black line the gold cloaks again most
guys there it was there like calling him
out he's like have you ever been past
the wall and he's like oh so goes the
head of the Kingsguard some you know
just all that crap so our to start the
gold cloaks and it was good to see him
back there you know so they they let him
off you know master Amon um you know
he's he has a soft spot for jobs he
knows John wasn't doing anything wrong
necessarily he was doing what he was
supposed to do but it sounds fishy
because he killed the half an corn hafen
and corn have [ __ ] hands was like the
baddest man north of the wall so what do
you think about being back you know what
was that like seeing Sam and everybody
was kind of quick I mean was there's a
lot of stuff it was just as just to have
them relay the information that he has
about the wildlings and their plans to
march on the wall so it was just more
set up in school it was just the CLE
also to clear out okay Jon Snow is not
in that much trouble it's not gonna get
hang for us we got to see John reflect
on Rob his death you know he said how he
was always jealous of his brother as you
know it's half brother and how you know
that I liked how Sam said you know hey
I'm always been jealous of you I think
it is because it's it's it's
it's real life there's always someone
that's wishing or NBC someone else yeah
not knowing that someone you know yeah
yes mm right you know there you're
thinking oh man I wish I could be like
that one guy but you know I I don't have
this or that it but really there's
someone else that's like in a different
position wishing they could do what you
were doing it was funny Jon Snow I think
a lot of people see even who've never
the book to read the books either way
could maybe I guess you could kind of
seem as the hero of the story maybe
maybe not you know he's not perfect but
I actually found the stuff going on with
your grits camp and the people you know
the wildly the wildlings found their
scenes more interesting let me see this
whole new group of people coming in
cannibals let's call them you know come
in and moving on their territory you
know they're all kind of planning now to
attack the wall from one from the south
and then obviously wants a what's the
name like the big bonfire Mance Rayder
likes a bonfire than I hope we see more
Mance Rayder I was very excited when
Ciaran Hinds got great I've never all
from he's also from Rome right and we
didn't really see him much last season
oh well and from what I heard he isn't
in the first three episodes so I'm
hoping further along they're gonna show
more of him they also had Johnston list
off the bunch of different groups right
wildlings and I guess that one we saw
the cannibals was one of them yeah yeah
that's pretty cool so I mean those guys
seem to even intimidate the other group
that's there you know I mean those guys
are seem kind of crazed or tall somebody
said they look like the people from
prometheus like you know the the
collectors are further from you so that
was interesting but again not much
happening you know on that side of the
world so let's move over before I know
Robbie all like we're sorry it's like
this was like what laughs that's the big
one everybody loves re-enter favorite
character let's go talk about Daenerys
Oh Danny Khaleesi over there getting
ready to head into marine I believe in
to a new city but she's trying to get
her army together and
the new actor playing Darrow's Doris doc
that can then I I forgot the name of the
guy but the the guy who ended up killing
his two partners yeah last season
totally different this contractor this
guy looks like eric bana he look like
Aris been a little bit yeah and the
other I'm sure people were confused that
don't know that a new carrot actor was
the other guy is going to fill in for
Jason Statham in the transporter series
but the other guy has away his face is
so different no long yeah like darker he
is dark brown yeah Italy different but
yeah that new care actors in that role
that is flamboyant no you can tell he's
kind of a playboy but he's not like good
guy was like flowery this guy's a little
he's a little different it'll different
way I liked him there's a little
different way of playing them just got
to get used to yeah it's just like oh
right they recast him I forgot about
that but that's a grey worm I like grey
worm he's kind of becoming his own his
own man like was nice seeing them doing
that little gambling thing who could
hold up the stored the longest I like
that also we got to see some dragons we
gotta see if they're big they're getting
a lot bigger they're getting more fierce
and then like Mormont pointed out you
can't really tame them you can't write
even her Denis races and other dragons
can't control them and she can command
them and have them do stuff but they're
trying don't get between them and their
food right that's this episode seems to
be a lot about is love people losing
control that illusion of control is it's
leaving they don't have that that's same
you know controller theam but apparently
they're marching to the mirror in this
other city but this other city knows
that they're coming and that they had
already liberated the slaves from two
different players like each slave for
136 miles yeah so that's leading on to 2
i'm sure a big bet another big battle
yeah of Khaleesi trying to free the
slaves right so I mean again you know
kelis you got to again like these
episodes you know Jessa are jumping
around from malaria Eric that's what the
Premier's are they are like let's hey
let's get reacquainted with some old
friends like oh this is what Danny is
doing this material this would all of
our people that we missed over the year
off almost 10 months that we had off or
doing so now I guess this gets the big
one everybody wants to talk about let's
talk about Aria are you in town yeah
that's team up on TV period there is no
yeah this is obviously my favorite part
of the whole episode I think most people
would agree because you get to see Aria
kind of grow somewhat into the person
that she wants to my comment which is
really like a cold-blooded killer sasson
we've got to see at the end because she
wants to get revenge she's unlike some
her sister Sansa sonses upset and sad
she's in Kingsley I really killing
anybody no she's her thoughts aren't
really of revenge her thoughts are more
like please i want to get away fries
people i want to go away I want to go
see my forever is left of my family
right and Arya is like no I'm gonna kill
these fools they're gonna get I'm gonna
all these people she lists off she wants
to kill them and no this is another step
along that way cuz we haven't really
seen her she's kill she killed one guy
at the end of last season yeah man she I
think she killed like a kid nobody hit
end of season one or no one at the end
but like when it was end of season one
yeah yeah he kind of the kid kind like
walk do ya it wasn't like semi accutane
throat spur of the moment thing then
well I ended last season she did
something killed that guy on purpose but
this time she takes it a step further
yeah I mean she's she's like she does
what villains do like I love the
incredibles you know Pixar she's
monotone gee I'm sorry i see'em not
monotone she has this mother called uh
she's going on a rant basically is you
know villains do they always stand over
you give a speech before they kill you
like that's what she's doing I love that
she's like you know reciting what he
said to the kid he's like wait what is
that he understanding at the last moment
then you see the glimmer of recognition
yeah but yeah it's great her in the end
hound have a great dynamic I mean that's
the thing about this show is that you
can take a lot of characters just two
characters right and make a whole show
out of them you know yet Tyrion and
brawn can do their own show Terry and
sir say can do that show Jaime and
Brienne could do their own show Arya and
the Hound are in and Jack Jack in you
want to spend it's like an episode and
did you were like no I mean it's too
short yeah yeah I mean I'm not gonna
mean it's good because Game of Thrones
he made up of the meat I mean it's
always just a good stuff you get every
episode but you wish you can spend more
time these characters like it's just
like a little bit of here a little bit
of it a little bit here and still we got
to go through this before we you know
leave is we got talking about like who
wasn't on you know there's still have
people we didn't see didn't see Theon
Greyjoy we didn't get to see Stannis or
the red woman you know Millicent road
you can see her no bran no no Hodor
Hodor everybody lies hold or so of
course no George and read and you know
the brother and sister and so still a
lot of characters to get to know varies
no little finger so still a lot of
characters that we haven't which is
great cuz you know we're gonna see him
I'm assuming next episode but it's just
so many characters in the story so many
yeah re is one of my favorite character
so I was glad cuz during the whole
episode like we hadn't seen her at all
and I was like oh they're just gonna
save her for next week I'm mad all right
and then of course that the big chunk at
the end is all about her and the fight
in the tavern I love that you know the
Hound was asking about the chickens like
you're gonna get me a chicken no get me
two chickens really and then at the very
last scene is him eating chicken on the
hall right yeah that was a great sing an
aria is on also on her own horse fine
got her pony yeah you know and she's
kind of realized look I can't leave this
guy hound yeah see if it says like
where's she gonna go what's she gonna do
she's gonna get killed yeah or raped or
more something Bad's gonna have to also
I think while she was watching him fight
she realized I can learn stuff from him
right I can learn how to fight from this
guy cuz obviously this guy's big but he
also knows how to fight right and I
think she's gonna learn from him and
eventually kill him yeah and what we
know that they're at least trying to the
Hound is trying to think about taking
her to the veil to lady Arryn who we saw
in the first season I believe you know a
little big kid that was you know
breastfeeding at an odd age um so
because he just wants to make some money
so you know it's gonna be I think a fun
adventure to see what see what see what
they get out this little still a lot to
come alright guys so would you think of
the season 4 premiere of Game of Thrones
let us know II thought you put your
constable on the website feature or calm
or on our YouTube channel think you're a
pro make sure to subscribe to that also
find us on Twitter let us know your
favorite moments were from this you know
very eventful up
the game of thrones you can find us at
thing here where I'm at Griffin de and
you can also check out our Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans make sure you like it and share our
videos on Twitter or Facebook and other
social media thanks
you